you've probably been receiving hundreds
of emails in the last few weeks from
every company whose website you've ever
visited and even some you haven't you
may have read something about gdpr
needing to update your privacy settings
gdpr
or the general data protection
regulation is for EU law governing how
your personal data can be used it has
recently been updated and strengthened
putting you back in control of your data
so what does that actually mean your
personal data will now we treat it as an
extension of you if a company wants to
use any information that identifies you
as a person so your name your address
but also your IP address or location
information then they need your explicit
consent to do so previously when
visiting a sites or purchasing something
online your personal data may have been
held in their system events do whatever
lights with or even passed it on to
others from now on companies will only
be able to use your data for the
original purpose you gave them
permission for this brings other
advantages such as making it easier to
change to a new email provider or
another service also if you no longer
want a company to have your data all we
have to do is request it and now
required to delete it all
previously enforcement was so weak and
punishment so low but large companies
would often just flout the rules now any
large company or public organization is
required to have a data protection
officer to ensure they're complying and
if they still don't we've insured hefty
penalties up to four percent of a
company's global turnover so even the
largest companies have a very strong
reason to look after your personal data
basically gdpr shows but we don't need
to get caught in a race to the bottom if
Europe sets high standards for knees
will often become a new global norm
and all because progressive parties in
the European Parliament fought for your
data protection
you